the new swimming pool designed has
provision for spectator seating and we
expect that I'll resolve a lot of issues
we have the the original hybrid sliders
is actually 40 years plus old so we are
absolutely looking at buying a brand new
awesome replacement for our current
homicidal goodness me probably a large
aquarium with a translucent sliding went
through the middle of the aquarium pool
prices are based largely on the ratio of
rates to user pays and by and large we
try to operate on a 50/50 models so the
cost to enter the pool is largely
determined by the expense to run the
pool and obviously the amount of rates
we get to run the ball yeah only now is
a demand driven absolutely and by way of
example some time ago we settled up in
the pool half an hour earlier when we
recognized there was demand the afford
so if in the future there is demand and
the evenings for longer every now is
there something we would certainly
consider so the current pulls and total
have about 2.4 million liters of water
and that water is recirculated through
filters and heat the elements in the
light there is a top-up of about 1% of
the total volume so so every day we're
adding about 30,000 liters from the town
supply if the plan is to add an
additional swimming pool on the same
site and the reason for that is we have
all the ancillary services we need for
running this wonderful the cafe the
change rooms and the light car bike for
example that makes more sense than
building a separate facility elsewhere
and over time well there isn't at the
moment so there's absolutely a plan to
expand our care plan place really is the
biggest issue we have at the moment so
today we're getting over 400,000
emissions a year and the pool was just
simply never designed for that many
people
the the schoolchildren coming into the
facility generally are there for the ilt
learned a strong program which is
incredibly successful and we see
somewhere around forty thousand children
every year getting proficiently provided
swimming lessons the trouble is is that
there's such a popular program the
demand on the facility has increased
such that we find we don't have enough
plane space to provide for our public
users as well so I've course a new swing
for witnesses were there absolutely